welcome to this video playing Franek jaw
from Nocturne played him two times and
12 times that sounds good I have no
particular memory though and brought
those games maybe six so that I have
Bishop d7 in case of a 4 I like to
answer a forward that move also friday
night a 5v SSS one way to go about that
what about Bishop g4 is a possibility
here from 94 oh it's just ignoring that
it's a bit surprising he's also sitting
at night e 2 in 92 can I make use of
that on something a5 before always I'm
always out for some stupid tricks a5
push up is free and I can still take now
that's not a bad move so what is this
here Bishop age 6 + f4 possibly okay
let's just set up for that on f4 night
h5 is good oops still going for that
okay I did I ruled out this move from 44
principal reason I mean just
just look strange but maybe he can do
that 95 maybe that that could be a point
may be okay if I go here start tactic or
something I don't see it ok it's just a
check be true ok I guy grabbed that I
really will okay so check check and
tonight f6 is what he wants to do
Knight f6 I'm taking place c6 moon jam
it will be difficult to try to win he's
really active
check
Jim I don't I don't really see how to
how to play for wind from this position
it's seems seems difficult I think I'm
very solid I mean he cannot really do
much but I'm really not sure how I'm how
I might be able to oh I forgot about age
six check actually that's a bit
embarrassing I thought Queen f6 but he
has just has aged six check hmm
hmm that's it's bad it's really bad
plane on my part shouldn't have allowed
allowed to the h pawn to age five Queen
g5 on Queen g5 I might have Ruby five
but queen hmm that's that's not easy
change e7 was really bad I was really
thinking I'm attacking the rook but
that's nonsense h5 is of course a good
way to to to to stop that ok so he still
has aged 6 in
ok
you can play first age six and then take
one m7 I forgot about that mmm now I
forgot about that ah what a bad game he
just this is really really bad losing
this position I mean yes compensation
but I don't think I should leave us like
that you can just go age six take f7 and
that set I don't know what he's thinking
about age 6 what is their defense I
don't see one some kind of maybe look
age five and couldn't be six check as a
defense wow that's devilish I didn't
even say I didn't plan that but it is
there now almost is we have to even
that's not working so age six is just
winning check will be six check
check okay okay at least at least I know
what to do that's that's often good news
and you at least know what moved to play
ok now I can check on creep liquin b6
check not sure how good that is but I
can do this it's not a problem here I
think nothing in particular yeah I can
chat check myself yes yet another check
coming Jeff King f1 and his kind of kind
of escaping right that's amazing
cecchini to me as checks on f8 and on f
form
hmm check Queen f7 quin gee Sam check
it's probably risky but i have f queen a
one-time warning check let's see check
here Jeff Cho to check here and see one
check like to get my look into into the
whole thing with check but I don't see
how I can check on c5 kinky tool they
have no rules Jeff fortunately chef no
muy have to have to have to perpetual I
think we have to drown are drawn
unfortunately and may okay i mean i was
completely busted so it's um it's okay
so i didn't I thought check maybe I
maybe i'm wrong but i thought yeah that
wins actually thought that wins and why
is that not winning i don't get it i can
go to g8 I don't don't see the
difference I think this just winced I
don't I don't know why I didn't do that
the only thing i have is chess this
year's is the only thing that yes a
little bit like a defense check our
gauge 626 okay that's not entirely clear
computers has wide winds which might be
true but that's not something easy to
play check okay check
check check yeah comp wants to really go
on the hunt maybe but what would always
have a perpetual so kind of amazed that
there is no not more but it's a computer
sense of Perpetual wow okay yeah what I
want to see want to see those were here
I went here yeah King is 7 s ridiculous
King g7 I really really overlooked that
so i have to go rookie 727 that was my
my general plan of Defense here this is
this thing then like 27 rookie 6 trying
to trade stuff he has compensation he
and us in this position but he shouldn't
like win outright this is this is not
simply not acceptable how I how I
defended them can I go look II 6 trying
to return return something might be
possible right yeah that's a draw
actually some kind of Perpetual at the
end why both kings are open so it's very
often will end in a perpetual okay well
thanks for watching